the girag on experience so we need if if
we can't clear away the myths that euro
America or white America whatever you
want to call it if we can't clear away
those myths that we continually face
every day every time I go into
Washington DC dammit every time I go
into the Wegmans there's a big
Washington football team
Tostitos potato chips with the
Washington football team name on there
and and the Redskins and was that an
offensive word yeah it's an offensive me
even saying that like right there is
that offensive yes yes not to everybody
but the majority of Native American
groups tribes they've all let the team
know that that that that name is
offensive and they still won't change it
they don't they say it's honoring it's
honoring Native Americans that term is
used and you see it in historic records
to count Indian skins or scalps that
have been taken from Indian people it's
an offensive it's not just derogatory or
demeaning but it's we should be really
clear what you're saying we've seen
skins and scalps I mean dead people yeah
yeah yeah and sorry oh no no worries
listen this is the number one reason why
I wanted to have you here yeah I want it
I want it from your perspective because
for us we get oh yeah that's an
offensive word here that's offensive I
heard that's offensive
mm-hmm the majority people are not
talking to someone who's deeply
ingrained in Native American issues and
culture like you're so you get explained
to us that you know me it makes sense
right if we of those it was you know
think about some derogatory term for
someone somewhere I mean even if it was
like
kind of derogatory like if they were
called the Washington Krauts and it was
all based on Germans like a lot of
German people probably be really pissed
off at that like hey you know that's
kind of shitty like why you calling us
that
but it's the Chiefs Kansas City Chiefs
are what other Native American names
there's been a ton of them right yeah
Braves there's a lot of Britons are the
Braves still around yeah yes they still
have that name so all is anybody give it
giving in and change their name I'm I
yes there has and there's been really a
movement with high school colleges and I
don't know the status of any you know as
far as NFL or national teams Syracuse
Syracuse University had a derogatory
mascot that they changed some years back
because of the tribes there there are
now in the state of New York
fought for that what was that
mascot I can't remember but now they're
there there's some kind of like orange
it's an orange super orange yeah it's
not hurting anybody exactly exactly but
but but if we're ever gonna fix these
issues I think we really need to start
with our public education system we need
to teach people that Indians are still
here we're still alive it's amazing how
many people don't even realize that that
Indian people exist outside of casinos
it is kind of crazy if you think about
it there's not another culture that gets
named it gets teams named after them
we're we have Indians all around us all
the time just go to the grocery store
and buy some butter or some baking soda
look at look at different yeah it pop
culture Tomahawk missile the Indian
motorcycle and and the Pontiac hada I
think an Indian head on its car back in
the day I think yeah it was an old pony
yeah it's it's all over our our culture
it's all around us but yet we don't even
realize that that what that means yeah
and so it really to many of us you would
think it would open up a dialogue about
about Indian people and and whether
we're going to choose to do something
different with this history because it
is our history it's our collective
history and we have throughout time
changed the narrative and stories of our
history you know when when we've all
realized that Columbus wasn't such a
great guy that took a long time yeah
yeah well what do you think about that
your Italian crazy it's crazy that it
took so long to figure out that he was a
sociopath and a murderer I mean what
would you read the accounts of the the
different religious people that were
traveling with Columbus wrote I forget
what they were what what their
designation was but there was one
Journal that detailed what they did to
Native American babies shattered their
heads on rocks and cut people's arms off
if they didn't bring their weight and
gold to them I mean horrific horrific
tales of torture and murder and it's
like how is this the guy that we have a
day off for how is this Columbus thing
you realize what Columbus was a
conqueror I mean he was just a symbol of
the times a 1492 it was a brutal time in
human history and when they arrived in
what I mean that really didn't even
arrive here but when they arrived
wherever they did arrive it was the
worst thing that could have ever
possibly happened to the people that
were already living there and that this
guy is somehow or another you know a
part of our folklore you know 1492
Columbus sailed the ocean blue and all
that nonsense and meanwhile he's a
[ __ ] murderer
and it's it's kind of crazy yeah they
knew this but it took until now I mean
didn't they change it to indigenous
peoples day well there's
still cities counties States that are
still in the process of changing that
I'm not sure I think there are some
cities in in California that have
already done that and you know celebrate
indigenous peoples day not named after
Columbus though right is it named after
another dude no what's it named after
Columbus it is giant statue in front of
City Hall change that [ __ ] Toledo you
got a Columbus hat on bro you piece of
[ __ ] I'm sorry I was trying to ignore
that okay I'm sorry
thanks a lot thanks a lot I feel really
welcome that's right the Cleveland
Indians another one I forgot about the
Atlanta Braves the Washington Redskins
it is nuts when you stop and think about
how many American teams are named after
Indians animals and Indians Columbus man
[ __ ] you Columbus change your name what
would they change it to named after a
lake or someone named it after a cool
Native American did that be okay yeah
all right who I would I would consult
with the Native Americans before right
they would have to be someone from Ohio
like what what nation is in Ohio well
there's not any now there are indigenous
peoples there but there are no federally
recognized tribes in Ohio Wow
so who are the indigenous people that
are not federally recognized I'm not
sure but I know that there was Indiana
Ohio that was Miami tribe there in
Oklahoma but there are you say Miami you
mean Miami this city no they're a tribe
people okay because you were saying that
earlier and I was I was gonna correct
you I was gonna ask you either have you
meant the city no no I'm so Miami is did
Miami get named after Native Americans I
don't know I don't know but I would I
would think so there's a lot of place
names that are named after indigenous
rivals
[Applause]